Speaker 1: . All right. Let's get back to the
phones and talk to a few more people. We take
calls via discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord. Let's go next to let's go to
Junie from Chicago. Judy, welcome back.
Speaker 5: I'm great. I'm glad to be back,
David. How are you doing today?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 5: Good, good. My question relates to Mike
Pence and his praise he's gotten recently. Okay.
So I've been watching, you know, the
hearings for the past, you know, a
week now. And they keep saying Mike Pence
has saved democracy. But in my opinion,
it just seems like Mike Pence just kind of did
his job and he shouldn't receive the praise
that he's gotten. Would you agree with that?
Speaker 1: I completely agree. I mean, listen,
it's similar with Liz Cheney. Like I get there's
some courage in breaking with your party. And she
said, hey, listen, Trump incited the insurrection
and Trump lost. And a lot of Republicans aren't
willing to say that. So compared to them,
you're like, Wow, that's pretty reasonable.
But no, you're elected to just do basic things.
And one of the things Mike Pence cannot do
is overturn election results. And so the idea
that he saved democracy. Well, okay. I mean,
I don't think he could have overturned the
election. I think he could have tried and made a
mockery of himself and, you know, the Constitution
in so doing. But to call people heroic defenders
of democracy merely because they didn't
attempt a coup is going a little bit too far.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's something I totally
agree because, you know, Mike Pence is still,
you know, a pretty terrible the you know,
Republicans. Absolutely. You know, like like his
policies are just like like I remember because I
used to live in Indiana and I remember, you know,
his anti-gay policies, which were just atrocious.
Yeah. You know, so so his this praise that he's
gotten has been fairly nauseating because, you
know, he's still just, you know, he did this
one good thing. But in the, you know, his long
history of being like a, you know, a political
person, he's just been completely terrible.
Speaker 1: Well, it's just it just shows how
far we fall. And it's like he lost and he left.
And we're saying it was a defense of democracy.
Right. And it's just it's it's it's the contrast
with what Trump did. I get it. But at the end of
the day, what happened is he lost and he left.
Speaker 5: Yeah. Yeah. I just completely agree
with that and. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And I
like you. I like your insight, so. Yeah,
so yeah. That's all I really wanted to, you know,
get off my chest and, you know, congratulations on
the baby, man. Thank you. That's really good.
Speaker 1: Thank you. All right,
Judy from Chicago, thank you for the call.
Speaker 5: No problem talking about your day.
Speaker 1: A lot going on there in Chicago.
You can tell it's very, very extreme.